à l'entrée de ce marché aux légumes de
new delhi un employé prend
systématiquement la température de
chaque client venu faire ses courses
les gestes barrières et des mesures
sanitaires semblent être respectée dans
ce quartier de la capitale indienne
pourtant le ministère de la santé a
rapporté une nouvelle hausse quotidienne
alarmante par rapport à ces dernières
semaines le virus circule en effet
rapidement dans les villes très
densément peuplés dont new delhi nous
avons peur mais nous devons quand même
surmonté ce réflexe chacun dans le monde
craint pour sa vie mais c'est aussi
nécessaire de travailler
la sensibilisation est nécessaire elle
permettrait de contrôler la propagation
du virus
le gouvernement craint qu'un demi
million de personnes ne soient
contaminés d'ici la fin du mois de
juillet
certains états du sous continent indien
en pleine phase de déconfinement
envisage de prolonger des mesures
strictes dans certaines villes du pays
ici à bombay des personnels de santé
font du porte à porte à la recherche de
personnes présentant des symptômes du
virus
nous déterminons si quelqu'un est
susceptible d'être contaminées ou non
c'est ce que nous faisons nous vérifions
leur température avec notre thermomètre
électronique et leur capacité
respiratoire avec notre oxymètre les
mesures de confinement instauré en inde
depuis fin mars ont été progressivement
levées les écoles métro cinémas et
salles de sport reste cependant ferme et
les vols internationaux sont toujours
cloués au sol le premier ministre
narendra modi a déclaré la semaine
dernière que le taux de mortalité était
sous contrôle mais que le pays traverse
est toujours un moment critique